the main topic at least in terms of the
time spent on it and the progress made
certainly is anti tax avoidance package
we now are close to an agreement and I
am confident that we to be able to reach
that in the June echofon Council we've
agreed Council conclusions today that
cover three broad areas first on urgent
and medium-term measures to be taken to
fight v80 fraud and to tackle the v8
egapp second area is on compliance
simplification measures for micro
enterprises and SMEs here we expect
receiving legislative proposals from the
Commission in the context of the digital
single market strategy third we provide
the Commission political guidance on VA
tre rates where ministers endorse the
idea of more flexibility for member
states on the implementation of the
banking Union full transposition by all
member states is almost delivered three
member states are in the final phases
and they have told us that in the coming
weeks and the latest mid-june they will
do the last bits and pieces of the
legislation finally on the European
semester we adopted conclusions on the
progress in the implementation of the
2015 country specific recommendation
including the in-depth reviews for 18
member states today we discussed two
proposals in particular the anti tax
avoidance package and the create the
action plan on tax avoidance Commission
proposal is an ambitious 18 specifically
calls for the OECD measures to be
implemented jointly as the EU level and
even to go behind this we're also
pleased that council has given its
strong political support to the
Commission's proposal on setting up a
common EU list of non cooperative
actions and coordinated defensive
measures together with a coy City
Commission is working at full speed on
this we hope member states can deliver
clear clear criteria for third countries
that do not live up to the
internationally agreed standards by
September finally as a council today
adopted conclusions on the Commission's
country reports which is a Commission's
analysis of the economic and social
situation in member states the reports
and ensuing discussions with national
authorities and other stakeholders
provide basis for a country specific
recommendations which Commission
proposed on 18th of me echofon is
expected to discuss this in more detail
in the next meeting in June